bonjour benjamin morel bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin avec
nous dans la matinale d'air france il y
a eu 925 milles rendez vous pris après
ces annonces des manuels macron est ce
que pour vous le chef de l'état a
convaincu alors l'objectif c'était
surtout d'une certaine façon de pousser
les non vaccinés à s'inscrire dans
l'urgence là dessus on peut considérer
que en effet et bien il ya plutôt une
mission qui a été rempli avec cette idée
que le variant delta par yvon et bien il
fallait pousser les français à très très
rapidement se vacciner parce qu'on va
éviter
du point de vue législatif du point de
vue réglementaire et bien entre ce que
dit le président la république et les
obligations qui peuvent être réellement
mises en misant classe vous avez
forcément un temps de latence ou que le
parlement se prononce etc
c'est la démocratie et c'est l'état de
droit donc eu l'idée c'était de donner
un sentiment d'urgence et là dessus
c'est plutôt réussi après le fait de
venir se faire vacciner en urgence ne
veut pas signifier se faire vacciner
avec plaisir et en tout cas avec une une
réelle un réel accord vis-à-vis de cet
acte là donc là vous pouvez avoir un
phénomène qui sera un phénomène de
vaccination massive
mais évidemment une partie des vaccinés
qui pourront en vouloir au chef de
l'état
oui on va en parler plus en détail avant
de rentrer justement dans le détail de
ces mesures benjamin morel le discours a
duré 27 minutes il a été à effectuer du
grand palais avec des infographies que
du doubs sur la forme mais ce qu'elle a
changé on a un emmanuel macron qui en
est fait à la fois a voulu se donner un
style très présidentiel
avec on va dire une un cadre qui conduit
à légitimer le poids politique et en
même temps justement avec ces
infographies avec cette volonté malgré
tout demeurer à ces pédagogues de copier
un peu ce qu'elle a fait son premier
ministre edouard philippe
il y a à peu près un an et dont il a vu
dont il a perçu que pédagogiquement et
bien ça pourrait être bien reçu par
l'opinion après est ce que ces deux
styles sont tout à fait soluble c'est
l'une des questions qui peut être poser
problème dans l'affirmation du style ici
est pas tant liée à cette conjugaison là
qu'à la conjugaison de mesures
sanitaires d'un discours solennel sur
des raisons sanitaires et ensuite du
déroulé d'un programme
et là en effet vous avez je dirais une
un changement de registre qui pour une
partie de l'électorat peut-être
déstabilise on vous l'avait dit
c'est une vaccination soula sous la
contrainte puisque il ya évidemment des
sanctions qui seraient prises notamment
pour les soignants voyez ce qu'on a dit
laurent jacot ville et le porte parole
du rassemblement national pour lui il y
aura clairement une fracture sanitaire
regarder
laurent jacques aubé les du
rassemblement national on voit bien
qu'il va y avoir une fracture sanitaire
entre ceux qui pourront se payer des
tests sanitaires
est ce qu'ils seront contraints de se
vacciner parce qu'ils ne pourront pas se
payer des tests alors les tests pcr ne
seront payants à partir du mois
d'octobre pour inciter les français à se
faire vacciner
ça veut dire que ceux qui auront les
moyens pourront ne pas se faire vacciner
et continuer à se faire des tests pcr et
pas les autres
qu'en pensez vous est-ce que cette
mesure est juste alors ça en effet l'un
des problèmes fondamentaux mais c'est un
problème fondamental auquel emmanuel
macron a tassé probablement poncet
l'idée encore une fois c'est d'orienter
de manière très très classique et très
classique en termes de réglementation de
réglementer les comportements pour faire
que ces comportements et plus de chance
de de se tourner vers une solution qui
est plus en accord avec intérêt général
en l'occurrence la vaccination il n'y a
pas un risque de fracture néanmois entre
ceux qui y évidemment qu'il ya un risque
parce que vous avez du coup par rapport
à cette réglementation ceux qui peuvent
s'en extraire et ceux qui ne le peuvent
pas ceux qui ne le peuvent pas
évidemment peuvent en vouloir à ceux qui
le peuvent et peut vendre bois en
vouloir la réglementation de leur
imposer quelque chose qui certes n'est
pas une obligation vaccinale absolue
mais defacto est une obligation
vaccinale pour eux donc là vous avez une
situation qui est une situation qui en
effet peut conduire à une forme
d'injustice mais qui très clairement a
pour objectif justement de pousser assez
massivement à la vaccination et qui
assume cette injustice dès lors que on
considère qu'il ya un intérêt public
le chef de l'état l'a dit lui même il va
falloir faire porter les restrictions
sur les non vaccinés après se pose la
question évidemment de la mise en oeuvre
de ces restrictions est ce que vous
pensez colle au processus législatif va
être simple processus législatif en tant
que tel
pas forcément poser problème ce qui peut
poser problème en revanche la
constitutionnalité des mesures alors
d'après ce qui était annoncé
il peut y avoir en effet des questions
qui peuvent se poser en termes d'égalité
on a un conseil constitutionnel qui tout
de même là dessus elle jurisprudence à
la fois un peu établi et relativement
souple par rapport à cette crise
sanitaire
donc le risque est assez mesuré il va
falloir voir ensuite mesure par mesure
comment est-ce que la chose va être
déclinée le vrai risque ensuite il est
plutôt du côté de l'application de la
norme et son applicabilité
parce qu'en réalité cette application de
la norme sata applicabilité elle repose
pour bout non pas sur l'état et sur la
police mais sur ce qu'ils vont devoir la
faire appliquer au quotidien l'as tu
auras terre etc etc
or c'est à la fois une charge
supplémentaire pour eux c'est quelque
chose également qui peut potentiellement
les priver d'une partie de leur
clientèle
pour toutes ces raisons là et bien il y
a il peut y avoir relativement problème
alors après vous avez d'autres ça ce qui
peut-être à la veille des vacances sont
des sas qui sont le plus radicaux pour
obliger la vaccination notamment les
transports blanc peut on sait que le
contrôle sera beaucoup plus important et
beaucoup plus réelle mais il va y avoir
en effet une question qui va se poser au
niveau du contrôle est une norme qui
existent mais qui n'est pas appliquée
c'est une norme en réalité qui perd son
crédit qui fait perdre son crédit à
l'ensemble de l'ordre de l'ordre
normatif et en matière sanitaire c'est
quelque chose de très bons mais le
ministre de la santé a confirmé
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants sous peine de sanctions ils ne
seraient plus payées à partir du 15
septembre s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés là
encore est ce que cette mesure est trop
contraignante ou pas selon vous des
mesures de toutes celles qui ont été
annoncées qui m'apparaît probablement la
plus problématique pour deux raisons
alors il ya la raison juridique tout de
même là il ya une interrogation est ce
qu'on peux pas m'en priver
un professionnel de son salaire sans
traitement parce que ilna il a refusé
une obligation vaccinale
ces questions auxquelles a priori je
n'ai pas la réponse est je crois pas
qu'on puisse encore la voir il va
falloir voir comment tranche le conseil
et le deuxième élément c'est que on a
affaire à une profession qui est une
profession sinistrée qui s'est battu
lors de la première lors de la deuxième
lors de la troisième vague qui certes a
connu un secteur de la santé mais qui le
moins que l'on puisse dire qui sait
qu'il n'était pas tout à fait à la
hauteur de ses attentes qui par ailleurs
été sinistrées avant même la crise donc
une telle mesure qui puisait vient
frapper au porte monnaie alors qu'on
aura besoin de ces professions à la
veille d'une 4ème vague
je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr que ce
soit bien reçu par les professionnels de
santé et pour ça je suis pas sûr que
cette mesure est extrêmement malade j'ai
besoin qu'il a pris à une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre que l'on connaît déjà et
des démissions qui se succèdent après 7
c'est bernard ou tendant à cause d'eux à
cause de ces différentes vagues
successives le chef de l'état qui a
également confirmé la mise en place de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
voyez les réactions à gauche justement
et ans et on en parle après le discours
de maquereaux va fracturé le pays
le massacre social des chômeurs va se
faire l'idée de la réforme des retraites
est relancé
les français doivent payer une crise et
des choix politiques donc ils ne sont
pas responsables cynique dangereux pour
l'unité du pays
réduire les indemnités des chômeurs
alors que la france compte 10 millions
de pauvres reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite alors que l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé des ouvriers de 59 ans le
seul cap de macron ce soir pourrir la
vie des gens modestes
est-ce qu'il a pris un risque emmanuel
macron selon-vous benjamin morel un
risque d'un regain de mouvements sociaux
à la rentrée
alors oui il a pris un risque et en même
temps d'un point de vue purement
scénique stratégique
il avait en réalité de marge de
manoeuvre assez limité qu'est-ce qui
fait le maquereau nice le maquereau
nisme c'est pas l'héritier d'une
tradition politique socialisme au
gaullisme ce qui fait le maquereau nisme
pour l'électorat d'emmanuel macron c'est
le fait de continuer à réformer sur le
programme et quand vous regardez la fin
de la qualité chez les jeunes la fin de
la crise de la première copie
un premier confinement ou même la fin de
la sphère benalla vous voyez qu emmanuel
macron reprend ses réformes déjà dans
les tuyaux reprend ce qu'il avait déjà
dans son programme comme solution aux
crises qu'il a connu justement parce
qu'il faut continuer à parler à cette
base électorale auquel il est pour
laquelle il est réputé et bien aller
jusqu'au bout de ses engagements et donc
il est un peu prisonnier de schémas
aujourd'hui et renoncer aux réformes qui
ont été des marqueurs c'est extrêmement
compliqué dans ce président de la
république beaucoup plus que pour un
autre
donc pour garder cette base il faut le
gagner il faut le faire et en même temps
en effet c'est pas le moment c'est pas
du tout le moment on est à la veille et
social on a la bei les crises
économiques et vous avez évidemment une
opposition qui sur ce sujet là va
s'opposer de manière dure et vous avez
toute une partie de l'opinion qui risque
de ne pas comprendre ces réformes
ben comprendre l'urgence pour des
raisons financières vu l'argent que l'on
met dans confinement et de ne pas
comprendre non plus leur urgence d'un
point de vue politique ça il a à peu
près compris pour la réforme des
retraites
en revanche pour l'assurance chômage qui
est déjà là en réalité un texte déjà
voté
eh bien il il décide de foncer à
l'automne vous pouvez en effet avoir un
regain de contestation dans ce pays pour
la simple et bonne raison que in fine et
la sortie de crise sanitaire comme toute
sortie crise conduit g en règle générale
à une repolitisation à une
radicalisation de l'électorat alors que
ce dernier généralement congelés durant
les périodes de crise il se réveille
après surtout à la veille résidentiel
très justement à moins de dix mois de la
présidentielle est ce que pour vous pour
terminer benjamin moral c'était un
discours électoral
c'était un discours évidemment
électorale et la fin du discours
détails enfin détail en tout cas
esquisse centraux les détails et
justement les grands axes qui seront
probablement ceux de la campagne de 2022
pour emmanuel macron donc la présidence
et les partis c'est pas non plus une
nouveauté
la question c'est que est-ce que c'était
bien de moments premièrement
et deuxièmement est ce que cette colonne
vertébrale qui expose aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron est vraiment la colonne
vertébrale qu'il peut tenir au vu d'une
situation au fond dément changeantes
profondément volubile dans le cadre de
cette de cette crise sanitaire
donc là il a pris un risque il a pris un
risque d'être jugée mal sur la forme de
devoir confondues ces deux sujets et il
a pris le risque également de lancer des
idées de lancer une campagne à un moment
où très clairement la visibilité ne lui
permettrait pas réellement de le faire
mais où afin de prendre de court ses
concurrents qui sont encore englués dans
les querelles internes et de la droite
et de la gauche
il était important pour lui de tirer
vite merci beaucoup d'engins morale pour
votre analyse ce matin dans la matinale
rt france